dans la vie soit tu gères l'idée c'est
de la merde
soit tu pas le train je m'appelle ruben
jablonski et je ne suis pas ce qu'on
appelle un mec cool baltringue la tiens
on regarde aux femmes rappelle noir et
pas à l'aise avec les jambes tu n'as
jamais oublié ton posé mais c'est aussi
mon cas moi j'ai passé de la drogue je
viens d'avoir un coup de coeur pour toi
tu pars demain matin à amsterdam avec
leur as tu me ramènes un petit paquet
moi je voudrais déjà vous dire merci
beaucoup pour cette proposition d'emploi
ce qu'on voit c'est dur est résumé c'est
donc ça me redonne à l'air d'être une
bonne vidéo connard comment tu sais qui
vient prenez des vélos
en plus contraintes route cd leapster ça
ne compte pas j'ai même pas numéro 1
vous n'ouvrez jamais le paquet ça vous
embête pas dérailler un petit peu les
chats parce que je crois je suis à la
rue les faits ce côté ça ira les chais
en cas de contrôle règle numéro 2 jamais
de contacts avec du liquide sinon la
came les morin et ce à quoi répond avec
ses chats c'est pas les serviettes
ça gêne
paris s'inquiète il est la cession lui
glisser un escroc
ramène mon paquet si tu veux pas être
issue
ce qui compte dans la vie
parce qu'on sait faire c'est ce qu'on ne
sait pas encore d
ils habitent même